en effet c'est une vie consacrée à
science en tout cas bon soir
pierre-gilles de gennes s'il est encore
besoin de vous présenter je dirais
qu'entre autres vous êtes professeur au
collège de france prix nobel de physique
vous c'est trop mais vous avez bien
d'autres titres je donne pas tous
revenons à cette semaine de la science
j'imagine que vous avez apporté votre
contribution dans dans les lycées lycées
dans lesquels vous n'êtes aller qu'à
partir de la 5ème je le rappelle pour
ceux qui nous avaient connu le
l'enseignement un peu tard mais j'aime
beaucoup aller dans les lycées j'ai
beaucoup fait autrefois et j'y reviens
dans des occasions comme ça le grand
bonheur si vous voulez c'est de parler à
tous les âges
depuis les games and quatrième jusqu'à
ce terminal ensemble et leurs profs avec
eux alors c'est dans le domaine des
sciences on est tous des enfants de
classes de 4e en ce sens qu est ce que
vous l'avez expliqué je dirais que un
exemple pour prendre un exemple c'est
l'histoire de benjamin franklin et west
franklin
c'est depuis les grecs que il faut de
l'huile pour calmer les vagues de la mer
mais lui à l'idée de savoir ça mieux
alors il va près d'un lac
comme nous au bois de boulogne on sait
très bien que quand il ya un petit vent
frais il ya des irisations benjamin voit
qu'en mettant une cuillerée d'huile sur
le lac qui est en fait à londres
eh bien ils calment les vagues seulement
c'est un vrais savants il fait plus que
ça il mesure la surface que ça cuillerée
d'huile à calmer sur le lac sa 100
mètres carrés est là il a fait des
découvertes des plus importantes de
l'humanité
s'il ya quelque chose que peut-être même
béatrice vous avez appris autrefois qui
est que un volume c'est le produit de la
surface par la hauteur il connaît la
haute icaunais la surface il connaît le
volume il va trouver la hauteur il va
mesurer la taille des molécules et vous
savez depuis les grecs depuis démocrite
ont paraphrasé en disant il ya des
atomes et des molécules mais c'était
dans les nems de la philosophie du jour
ou franklin fait cette expérience on
sait de quoi on parle on sait combien
grand est l'objet dans ton par jean
marie merveilleusement bien
comment réagit les petits français sont
curieux et veiller parce que je sais
vous allez aussi dans d'autres pays je
dirais que les français sont pas les
plus brillants parce qu'ils sont le
produit
location qui est quand même très
strictes les six volets comparé images
et des souvenirs par exemple à tobago à
trinidad dans le nord de l'angleterre
dans des endroits comme ça ou quand je
pose des questions à la fin ils viennent
beaucoup plus vite dans ces milieux là
que chez nous on sent que là on a
quelque chose a changé dans l'autre
alors justement peut-être que cette
semaine de la science devrait changer
les choses
je dirais que c'est une sorte de
passerelle entre les chercheurs et les
néophytes que nous sommes
est ce que c'est une semaine à libye est
ce que c'est une semaine qui sert
vraiment à quelque chose je me suis
demandé mais je crois de plus en plus
que ça sert vraiment à quelque chose
voyez quelque chose qui transparaît même
dans ce que vous montriez tout à l'heure
le public est très souvent inquiets de
la science ils la trouvent mais d'un
sentier de la trouve incompréhensible
un cas extrême en ce moment c'est les
milieux littéraires qui sont extrêmement
méfiante formation souvent pour des
raisons un peu corporatives mais une
fois pour de bonnes raisons
et là il ya quelque chose à faire
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas vraiment
ce que c'est que la science vous médias
vous êtes un peu responsables
et ça se voyait là ce que vous montrez
c'est les grosses machines les robots
les gros trucs qui se voit bien en vie
c'est vrai et je suis sensible à la part
du rêve mais je vous assure que la part
du rêve elle existe aussi bien chez la
majeure partie des petits groupes de
sciences qui sont des gens qui
travaillent comme des orfèvres comme des
horloges est sur le point de vous
aligner nous l'expliqué plus souvent la
semaine de la science pour moi c'est
alors dans votre laboratoire justement
si vous parlez avec cette passion j'ai
envie de dire avec une fraîcheur tout à
fait intacte
vous êtes un artiste vous êtes un poète
ou vous avez envie simplement de
soulever des montagnes
moi je suis à gros bras droit mais il ya
des gens que je vois pas forcément avec
moi qu'ils sont exempts dire je pense
par exemple aux jeunes maroc il ya
quelques années
travaillant dans un hangar qu'il décide
de faire une expérience d'hydrodynamique
difficile il a pas un sou il achète deux
lames de rasoir il l'aimé tout près
l'une de l'autre
il fait passer à travers cette mine
forte une solution de polymères y trouve
un phénomène extraordinaire
voilà la science qu'ils ont alors est ce
qu'il ya en france une crise de
vocations comme il semblerait que ce
soit le cas une fuite des cerveaux
oui je sens plus la fuite et ça c'est
quelque chose de tout nouveau pour nous
pendant des années des jeudis en
très heureux en france on ne perd pas ne
cherche depuis quelques années ça n'est
plus vrai et j'en vois en ce moment même
c'est moi aussi qui vont rester aux
états unis alors qu'ils étaient en
principe pour un an seulement
ça c'est une grande tristesse et c'est
la faiblesse de notre système
universitaire qui est un système très
traditionnelle avec beaucoup trop de
tout recrutement pas du tout d'appel à
l'extérieur on ne vit dans un monde trop
vieux
alors dernière christian très rapidement
claude allègre et et scientifique je
crois que c'est de la tectonique des
plaques il est pris par ses fonctions
ministre aujourd'hui quel regard vous
portez sur le politique il a changé vous
le connaissez bien les côtés ouais
j'aime bien le fait d'abord qui dit les
choses franchement et ça on n'a pas vu
beaucoup de désir qui le disent il a ses
défauts il est très conquérant et cetera
mais il a une vision très saine des
problèmes par exemple de celui que je
disais du fonctionnement des universités
ils essayent de remuer la fourmilière
mois dans toute la mesure de mes moyens
j'essaie de l'aider
merci des jeunes d'avoir un répondait à
une question
venez plus souvent au revoir